Traductor: Catherine Plaut
Revisor: Frank Zegarra
Quiero comenzar
contándoles algo que sucedió
hace más de 100 años en Inglaterra,
en un pueblito que pudo haber sido
en cualquier parte del mundo,
en el cual había un concurso.
En una feria del ganado,
había un toro en exposición,
la gente tenía que adivinar
cuánto pesaba ese toro.
Empezaron a participar,
anotaban en un papel,
lo entregaban al dueño
y hubo un ganador,
que fue quien más se acercó
al valor del peso del toro.
Lo interesante de esto,
es que en un momento apareció
Francis Galton, un pensador de la época,
e hizo algo bastante sencillo.
Hizo un promedio
tomando todos los valores,
ese promedio era muy parecido
al peso real del toro.
Es decir, el toro pesaba 1,199 libras
y el valor era 1,197.
Una precisión casi que asusta.
¿Qué es lo que quiere decir esto?
Que hace más de cien años que sabemos
que existe la inteligencia colectiva.
Lo que yo me pregunto:
¿Sabemos cómo hacer uso
de esta inteligencia colectiva?
¿Sabemos cómo formar parte de ésta?
Porque la capacidad que tiene un cerebro
de resolver un problema es determinada,
unos se acercaban más o menos,
otros se alejaban,
unos se alejaban muy por arriba
o muy por abajo,
pero la capacidad que tiene
un súper cerebro,
compuesto por ochocientas personas,
que fueron las que participaron,
tiene un potencial capaz de resolver
un problema como éste,
con un grado de precisión
bastante interesante.
Esto es algo que nos preguntamos,
mi equipo y yo,
como estudiantes de la UBA,
diseñadores industriales
graduados de una carrera,
en la cual nos encanta
solucionar problemas.
Nos encanta transformar
la tecnología, el diseño,
para solucionar problemas reales
de la sociedad.
Uno que se nos presentó es éste:
Es la impresión en Braille.
¿Qué problema hay con esto?
Que no hay contenido,
no es accesible.
¿Por qué? Porque no hay una tecnología
que logre imprimir en Braille
y que sea accesible.
Las impresoras Braille son muy costosas.
Este es un problema para la educación,
para la cultura, para la comunicación.
Es tan importante la impresión en Braille
para las personas ciegas,
como la impresión en tinta
para las personas que ven.
Entonces dijimos:
"Buenísimo, tenemos un problema,
algo que hay que solucionar".
¿Qué es lo primero que hace
un investigador?
Muchos de Uds., si investigan,
si son investigadores, deben saber.
Primero analizamos,
¿qué es lo que existe?
Encontramos que, en Internet,
había un montón de vídeos subidos
de gente que ya había desarrollado,
ya se había dado cuenta
de esta problemática.
Habían creado impresoras Braille
hechas desde cero,
reciclando impresoras de tinta,
en escuelas técnicas, en universidades,
gente en sus casas,
que no son académicos.
Dijimos: "¡Genial!".
Empezamos a analizar
todos estos vídeos.
Teníamos muchas dudas.
Empezamos a ver:
¿Cómo resolvió tal aspecto?
¿Cómo resolvió tal cuestión?
Cosas que son detalles fundamentales.
El problema que teníamos,
era cuando preguntábamos:
¿Cómo resolviste tal cosa?
No nos respondían.
Pero, ¿por qué?
Porque tal vez, ese vídeo lo subieron
hace mucho tiempo,
y con una cuenta que ya no usan,
o no se acuerdan,
porque fue hace 5 años,
o directamente, no te lo quiere decir.
Te dice: "No, este proyecto es mío,
¿quién eres tú?".
Eso también pasa mucho.
Esto es algo que es bueno hacer,
yo me hago cargo de esto,
como estudiante,
seguramente, acá hay muchos estudiantes
de las universidades,
sobre todo, los que pertenecen a
rubros de generación de contenido,
es bueno plantearse,
¿Cuánto de ese contenido,
está realmente disponible a la sociedad?
no está perdido en alguna PC,
en algún disco rígido
por ahí tirado,
en algún formato que ya no es válido,
que ya no existe?
La verdad, muy poco.
Entonces, nosotros dijimos:
"Bueno, acá tenemos una problemática.
Tenemos este super cerebro,
está presente,
están todos los actores,
está ese potencial,
pero no se está utilizando".
El problema no es de tecnología,
El problema es
la transferencia del conocimiento.
Es decir, lo que nosotros
propusimos hacer es:
Primero, recambiar el problema:
"No era éste, era éste".
Luego, empezar a imaginarnos,
¿qué es lo que se podría hacer?
¿Qué es esto?
Una impresora al estilo de:
"Ármelo usted mismo".
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Una impresora Braille, que una persona
pueda hacerla en su casa, en un taller,
con mínimas herramientas,
con mínimos conocimientos técnicos,
que no sea resultado
de un proceso productivo convencional,
es decir, que no salga de una fábrica.
También, ¿qué es lo que queremos
hacer esencialmente?
Queremos empezar a trabajar en bloques,
uno por encima del otro.
Es decir, no conocimiento dispersado
como ladrillos dispersos,
sino conocimiento sumado
para generar un proyecto en común,
no sólo en la investigación y desarrollo,
sino también en la producción.
Lo que estamos haciendo,
es esto: "Ciencia Abierta",
u "Open Source",
como se conoce en inglés.
Para los que no saben nada del tema,
les comento que es algo que ya existe,
se los voy a explicar sintéticamente,
en dos partes:
Primero, tiene que ver con esto:
con el ya mencionado "súper cerebro",
con utilizar ese potencial
para resolver problemas,
para generar un desarrollo.
Uds. me dirán, "Pero, ¿cómo se ve?
¿cómo es?".
En mi experiencia, se ve así:
Se ve como un montón de gente
trabajando en Lugano,
en San Miguel, en Lavallol,
en Bernal, en La Plata.
Algo que comenzó
como un trabajo práctico, académico,
y terminó siendo un proyecto
que siguió, tomó vuelo,
de gente trabajando,
complementando conocimiento,
alguno sabía más de electrónica,
otro sabe más de programación, de diseño,
empezando a trabajar colaborativamente
en un mismo proyecto,
algunos académicos y otros no.
¿Qué resultados produjo?
Una impresora Braille que resulta
10 veces más económica,
mucho más accesible, con la capacidad
de imprimir el código Braille.
No sé si Uds. alguna vez
desarmaron una impresora de tinta,
que se les haya roto en su casa.
¿Cómo son adentro?
Son muy complejas,
hay un millón de piezas.
Es algo que llevas al servicio técnico,
y te dicen: "No, no se puede reparar,
la tienes que tirar y comprar otra".
Porque es complejo,
y como todos sabemos,
está pensado para que sea así.
Nosotros, los diseñadores industriales,
lo sabemos mejor que nadie.
Pero acá, si Uds. se fijan,
está sintetizado el diseño,
está simplificado al mínimo,
para que cualquiera lo pueda entender,
lo pueda armar, ensamblar,
incluso lo pueda reparar,
si se llega a romper alguna parte.
Empezamos a usar, por una parte,
piezas estándar,
que son piezas fáciles de conseguir,
son accesibles, económicas,
en cualquier parte del mundo
se pueden conseguir,
no son un repuesto que después,
no sabemos dónde buscarlo.
Por otro lado, electrónica Arduino,
que para los que no conocen,
es una metodología electrónica
para gente que no sabe de electrónica.
Es decir, para principiantes,
donde yo compro las plaquetas,
las enchufo como me dicen
que lo tengo que hacer,
les bajo el cerebro,
y ¡ya está!
Lo más interesante,
es la impresión 3D,
como, por ejemplo, las piezas celestes que
se ven en cualquiera de las dos pantallas.
Estas piezas impresas en 3D son claves,
porque permiten descargar un archivo,
llevarlo a la impresora 3D y voilá.
Tengo una pieza de precisión,
que es igual si la imprimo acá
o en cualquier parte del mundo.
Uds. me dirán: "Bueno,
¿pero quién tiene una impresora 3D?".
"¿No era una herramienta accesible?".
La verdad es que las impresoras 3D
ya no son algo del futuro,
no es algo de lo que vamos a hablar.
Sino es una realidad, ya sucede.
Hay muchas personas
con impresoras 3D,
en todas partes del país,
en todas partes del mundo.
Y, ¿por qué?
¿A qué se debe?
Se debe justamente a que, también,
hay impresoras 3D "open source",
de ciencia abierta.
Es un proyecto que ya existe,
impresión 3D, en realidad, es algo viejo.
Por ejemplo, si ustedes ven estas fotos,
la que parece más cara de las dos,
es una impresora 3D industrial
que salió de una fábrica.
Son carísimas,
nadie puede tener una en su casa.
Hace tiempo que ya existen.
Pero la que está al lado,
por ejemplo, se llama Prusa I3.
Es un modelo de impresora "open source",
que fue diseñada colectivamente,
colaborativamente,
es decir, muchas personas
que empezaron a desarrollar,
a contribuir en un mismo proyecto,
a generar un diseño
que también utiliza piezas estándar,
también utiliza piezas hechas en 3D.
Empiezan a generar un diseño
que es fácil de ensamblar, de reparar.
Se empiezan a generar versiones, incluso,
diferentes versiones de modelos como éste,
de los cuales hay otros,
pudiendo descargar los planos de Internet.
El otro eje importante,
hablé que hay dos para definir
el "open source", en nuestra experiencia.
El otro,
que también es muy importante,
tiene que ver con
la soberanía del conocimiento.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Que la ciencia se encuentre liberada,
descentralizada.
Porque generalmente,
si nosotros nos ponemos a pensar,
el conocimiento se encuentra
en una entidad,
a la cual nosotros tenemos que acceder,
pedirle permiso, y tal vez,
podemos acceder a ese conocimiento,
o tal vez no.
Tal vez es un secreto.
En cambio, de esta manera,
empezamos a trabajar generando redes,
colectivamente en un mismo proyecto.
Y no solamente a nivel mundial,
sino también a nivel país,
a nivel región, a nivel ciudad.
Empezamos a tener una conexión
que es muy interesante,
porque compartimos una misma realidad
económica, social, cultural.
Es interesante pensar en
este amalgamiento territorial.
También es importante,
como estudiante universitario,
en mi caso, de la universidad pública,
seguramente aquí hay muchos graduados
de universidad pública,
darnos cuenta que
tenemos la responsabilidad,
no solamente de defender
la educación pública,
cada vez que se encuentre vulnerada,
sino también de la responsabilidad
de hacernos cargo de
que la ciencia sea de todos y para todos.
Muchas gracias.